[Music]
I know there was pain but I wouldn't do
this hold on till Monday baby stop no
break free break from jeans I'm Wilson
and Phillips if Hollywood looking for a
new comedy team may I suggest Reynolds
and Gyllenhaal our Carly still had
literally no idea what was gonna come
out of their mouths when they sat down
to talk about their new thriller life
will just hit theaters today I'm going
on even a simple question about working
with wires couldn't get Carly as
straight as unleashing your inner kid
are a little uncomfortable which one
hope they're posed yeah the issue I had
mostly was working you the wires were
haha a variety of clauses in this
contract and I actually come face to
face with me weirdly enough here we are
perfect for you don't know is I'm in
Marin County Northern California right
now at Skywalker Ranch watch this
SCI hologram yeah can't feel that can't
feel that can't feel that no cannot feel
any of that
my and or any of that yeah a twit
foundation ha ha ha ha ha watching this
duo's outerspace shenanigans on set was
Rebecca Ferguson playing the crew's
doctor
I like Caesar River they seem to have
developed bro man no they've used
they've made up this word just to steal
the limelight from this film this is a
bro-down we're like a tribe Rohtak
they're like molded into one person to
delay personalities molded into one the
best days were them on set together yeah
not just Ryan not just Jake you need to
suppose that's beautiful
he's calling Jake took his bromance with
Ryan to a new level last night on Late
Night with Seth Meyers just to prove
they were buds
Jake FaceTime here's what I'm doing
pushing baby strollers
I'm gonna get my lips done now another
thing we found out there was a lot of
singing going on during production they
said everybody would sing their lines
during rehearsal honestly I don't know
how they ever finished making the movie
[Music]
you